a monk seeking guidance from Joshua the
master of a Zen monastery asks doshu if
he will teach him the way to
enlightenment
in response as Oh Xu asks the monk
have you eaten your meal the monk
replies yes I have then go wash your
bowl says o Xu at that moment the monk
was enlightened right off the bat you
might find this anecdote to be abrupt
and confusing with further thought you
might try to figure out why what the
meal and the bowl might represent and
what the metaphorical lesson might be
after more thought you might conclude
that it all appears to have no point
with this you would be correct it
doesn't however in this discovery you
would have realised the point the point
being to not have one so I guess
technically you would have also been
wrong you might find this completely
contradictory and foolish again you'd be
correct this is also the point with only
a little dissection this simple
seemingly pointless riddle reveals to be
a whirlwind of progressive
contradictions and confusions when put
through the analytical mind how can it
have a point by not having one how could
it mean anything by not meaning anything
how can one argue for it and against it
at the same time this paradoxical and
brain breaking riddle is known as a
Cohen a Cohen is a riddle or dialectic
meditation device used in Zen Buddhist
practice that is intentionally designed
to at least on the surface be unclear
and obscure it's point is not to provide
a conclusion or answer to the question
presented but rather to disregard the
relevance of the answer to detach itself
from the functions of conclusion and
singular resolution there are over a
thousand known Cohen's that follow this
format used to test and challenge Zen
Buddhists and reveal the obscurity of
life and the limits of the mind in
general life is uncertain confusing and
paradoxical as hard as we work against
this it mostly remains so no matter our
efforts every time we believe we have
some understanding or control over life
like water in the palm of the hand the
tighter we squeeze the further it eludes
our grip sciences religions and
philosophies make sense of the world
through various methods some more
successful than others
but nonetheless all face the inevitable
limits of themselves the human mind and
the time in which they are erected by
sheer lack of alternatives we understand
the world with thoughts and words
through which we can create systems of
order and understanding like logic story
social structure and so on this can
greatly assist our ability to survive
co-exist communicate deal with physical
stuff and so on however thoughts and
words of course can only describe and
understand the world with thoughts and
words as a result the economic sense of
what exists beyond thoughts and words
which a great measure of life arguably
does like any tool thinking and language
are limited to the confines of their
abilities like a hammer cannot screw in
a screw and a nail cannot cut a board of
wood the human mind cannot accent's of
the mindless a hammer can perhaps smash
a screw in and a nail can perhaps split
a board of wood like the mind can
perhaps consider life but none of these
items or tools fully suit the jobs they
are carrying out and thus will fall
short in their abilities to properly
complete them Acco an embodies this
notion as opposed to most stories ideas
and answers that attempt to fight
against the concept of obscurity and
absurdity in life by using defined
structure logic and resolutions the
cohen harmonizes with the absurdity of
life and disregards the need for
conclusive answers in rough terms zen in
general is founded on this
synchronization with the obscure and
abstract to put it in context zen is a
subset of buddhism which was founded and
initially practiced somewhere around the
6th century in china and then further
popularized in japan thereafter buddhism
is considered by many to be a religion
but unlike most religions and even most
philosophies zen buddhism is not
concerned with concrete ideas and
concepts and thus is not really much of
a belief system at all rather it is
considered to be more of a state of
being in other terms it is a way of
living in accordance with one's
limitations to articulate and understand
things in any absolute sense and living
more off intuition and spontaneity which
even here misses the mark by attempting
to use words to describe it
paradoxically in the attempt to define
zen
you've already incorrectly defined it
Alan Watts a famous popularizer and
philosopher of eastern ideas especially
that of Zen Buddhism explained that Zen
is trying to point to the physical
universe so that you can look at it
without forming ideas about it instead
of saying life is this or that Zen says
life is and what is is unclear and
always changing at least in terms of
words and ideas which is to say the
universe is not to be packaged or
structured in some human or rational way
even if it could be but rather it is to
be experienced from the perspective of a
passenger to it flowing with it and
avoiding attachment to things within it
that might make one stuck or rigid it's
as if we are all swimming or floating
down a river in which there are rocks
that extrude out of the rivers surface
these rocks represent various things and
ideas that might be appealing or seem
reasonable to grab ahold of and stop
ourselves from going further down the
river however if we stop to hold on to a
rock we stop moving the water continues
to flow beneath us yet we remain stuck
and rigid Zen suggests that in this we
will begin to experience an increase
pain and suffering that arises from
being attached to something and
disconnected from the fluid movement of
activity happening around us in Zen this
movement is referred to as the DAO or
the way at risk of adding further
confusion and paradox to an already
confusing and paradoxical thought
experiment a Cohen does not appear to
suggest that we should cease asking
questions or thinking about the answers
to questions or anything of that sort
Cohen's did not spring up out of lack of
thought or contemplation but out of a
specific sort of contemplation a
self-referential thinking that denies
its ability to be a single concrete and
universal thing that answers or
understands what might exist beyond
itself Zen and the lesson of the Cohens
suggests that we should flow with life
ask questions contemplate them but not
become tricked by any singular idea or
answer that might tempt us into a final
resolution for it is likely nothing more
than a mirage of the mind this is of
course extremely difficult especially
since we tend to extract our identities
out of our beliefs and ideas and thus
our mind works very hard to hold on to
them
arguably it is unlikely that we will
ever be able to fully avoid being
tricked by this function of the mind and
ego even holding on to the idea of not
holding on to any ideas is in fact
holding on to an idea however perhaps by
considering the lesson of the Cohens
the more practical point is to help
remind ourselves of the playfulness of
most things to see through the contrived
to take ourselves a little less
seriously and to open up to the
possibility of new ideas experiences and
people that we might otherwise feel
disconnected from or in conflict with
just like how the center of a tornado is
calm with little to no motion despite it
being surrounded by a coil of rapid
violent winds we can live in the center
of the tornado of knowing and unknowing
and still remain calm and at ease
despite the surrounding storm of
contradictions and paradoxes regardless
of our religious philosophical or
spiritual beliefs
perhaps the lesson presented by the
Cohens applies to all all our sciences
philosophies religions and everyday
questions inevitably will face the
limits of themselves a Cohen and Zen in
general let us know that this is OK and
points us to the bigger picture the
riddle of which all riddles and stories
emerge and like all great riddles this
bigger picture must remain unclear
funny obscure and open to interpretation
to be it at all
[Music]